this is my hell no this is not your
house now what's your name my name is
Bell welcome and I'm 72 years old
what do you make of that forest sounds
confused to see that the voice on this
tape is coming from an 11 year old girl
they're calling it England's Amityville
there is a family that desperately needs
our help
after everything we've seen there isn't
much that rattles either of us anymore
but this one this one still wants me
does it feel like the voice is coming
from inside you oh no it's coming from
behind me
I got being used Jannetty all right
Curtis
she's such a good comment without an
oppressing spirit we'll try to enforce
you to commit the ultimate selfie what's
that
murder-suicide or both you believe us
them sensing a presence I'm not sensing
anything all I can sense is their own
fear let me bleed it what is happening I
had a premonition of your death
the family's just a pond something
inhuman wants to kill you
if we keep doing this
you're going to die
the name of the Father
the Holy Spirit